MINNESOTA.
>> Darren: WELL, WE KNOW CRAIG
BERUBE AND THE MAJORS
HT
AND NOW THE PUCK COMES FREE AS
PERRON GETS IT  THAT'S KICKED T
BY THE NET,
PUT THE PUCK THERE.
IT'S SIMPLE BASICS OF HOCKE
TYLER BOZAK LOST IT AND BRENT
BURNS FOR THE SHARKS. COUTURE C
BACKHAND FLIPPER RIGHT DANGEROU.
WATCHED THERE BY SUNDQVIST AND
BROKEN UP BY THE BLUES AND NOW .
AND O'REILLY, HE WANDERS IN A
SHOT AND OFF THE AS A EY GAME YD
.
AND WHAT A SAVE AND NOW THERE,
BONINO AND A GREAT GOAL AND A SY
HUSSO.
>> Darren: TERRIFIC SAVE BY THE.
>> John: AND WE WILL GET A ON I.
>> John: AND IT IS A BIT OF A
RISK DARREN IF YOU KNOW, IF YOL.
OBVIOUSLY ON THE RIGHT SIDE, SEE
THED IT WAS A RELATIVELY
EASY-LOOKING GOAL.
IT'S STICK AT THE
BLUES BENCH AND IS HIT BY
AND THAT GOES WIDE.
AND THE BLUESDEDO TODAY WITH TH
DOWNED LOOKED LIKE A CONFIDENT
GROUP GOINGING TO TAKE CHARGE OF
IT AND C
4:10 LEFT HERE IN THE FIRST
PERIOD.
AND NOW BORTUZZO.
ANDY KARLSSON.
>> Darren: IT LOOKED THE
WEAK SIDE AS THE DEFENSEMEN END
UP -- THEY'RE STILL ON THE  UP,
PRETTY GOOD PRESSURE, MOMENTUMZU
SEE HIS HEADS-UP ABILITY AND THE
WAY HE SEES THE DAHLEN HANDS ITO
BURNS.
IN ON THE WING TO  FORMER NHLer.
AND THE BLUES SLOW IT DOWN PLAY.
EXECUTION FROM THEIR OWN ZONE.
WE MENTIONED BEFORE NOT, DO AND
IT COMES OUT.
>> Darren: TREMENDOUSREEN,
THAT'S JUSTIN FAULK.
WENT RIGHT TO THE
AND THE SHARKS, T
KARLSSON.
AND THAT PASS COMES UP THEALONE.
AND HE JUST WHIFFED ON THE SHOT.